well we talk a lot about it the west is
suffering through a long and crippling
drought
today we could reach a new and painful
milestone when lake mead hits its lowest
level on record
bianca holman is live with a closer look
at what this means for us
good morning bianca hey good morning
sheri well for the past 85 years the
reservoir we know as lake mead has
provided california
arizona and right here in nevada power
and water but today that reservoir it
could reach the lowest levels it's
reached
since being filled in the 1930s some
amazing
statistics there and it's another sign
that a long drought our region has
endured
for years the u.s bureau of reclamation
says that the lake level will probably
keep falling until november
that's going to affect everything from
recreation to hydro power
already nevada and arizona are expecting
to get less
water from colorado river starting next
year but the continued drop in water
levels really impacts the entire
western u.s especially for farmers
so next year we're going to get about
25 percent less water means we're going
to have to fallow
or not plant 25 percent of our land
so many farmers are rushing to dig wells
to tap into that ground
water and also coming up in the next
half hour i'm going to explain how
again these lowering water levels at
lake mead impact us here
in the valley and again what we're
trying to do to again
really fight that drought and fight
those lowering water levels reporting
live here in studio b bianca holman
8 news now